did you guys see that down syndrome
Barbie thing oh yeah yeah we talked
about it today
yeah well I thought when I first I was
like oh that's cool like I didn't have a
problem with it why would I be mad about
Down syndrome Barbie and then Matt Walsh
made the good point he was like this is
very pro-life I think this is a good
thing and Crowder actually made fun of
it and I I wonder if Crowder actually
stopped to think about what it means to
have a Barbie that is has Down syndrome
when one of the one of the principal
talking points on abortion is to abort
people with Down Syndrome yeah and
that's crazy to me because like we're
not talking about a baby with no heart
or no brain or no face like if if a
doctor is like your baby's not growing a
face this is like a serious problem
there's some there's some deep ethical
questions about having some like you
know a baby be born with like no senses
whatsoever
still a hard question about whether you
terminate that life but now we're
talking about a functioning human being
you just happen to not like down to the
idea of aborting children just because a
Down syndrome is so offensive to me like
that is that is literally just aborting
a child because you know the child will
not be as smart as other people it'll be
you know it will happen think about what
that means it's it's appalling stuff
where the culture is going horrifying
think about it think about what that
means of the criteria for abortion is
this individual on average will be
shorter less attractive and a lower IQ
We Believe now I I
don't I don't I don't like to say that
because there are a lot of people with
Down Syndrome who have very prominent
productive lives and are good people and
deserve their lives and it's psychotic
to me that you think they should not be
alive by virtue of what they look like
or or how their thought process or
whatever but but if you think about why
they're deciding to abort
people with Down Syndrome the criteria
is simply if we're able if a doctor is
able to test for perceived intelligence
physical stature strength or appearance
you're going to start having designer
babies from every parent the doctor is
going to be like uh your child is
expected to be five foot seven oh abort
I mean but to be honest with you right
now we're we're aborting kids because
for no reason like yeah literally
literally no reason I don't feel like it
but also it's like convenience if we're
losing kids because of climate change
and because the world is there's
perceived that the world's going to end
in 10 years and that can't seems to be a
constant argument that's being made for
why you shouldn't have kids it used to
be that environmentalists could be just
ignored and you could just be like well
they're annoying they're you know or
they're whatever nowadays like when it's
when it's talking about you know they're
advocating for for not having kids
they're they're just yesterday there was
a bunch of climate activists in DC
blocking the road makes me miss Peta uh
yeah I mean
like our best allies it's just people
against climate
physically I like I like roadblocks
though breaking toss I think I like
roadblocks I like it when the
environmental people uh block the roads
because everyone is good for us because
yeah well I don't I don't you can think
whatever you want to think my my
attitude is they've stepped one foot
over the line and stopped and that is
the amount of pressure we're willing to
accept in people complaining about the
system where we prevent if you if you
don't give people a pressure release and
a means of feeling like they're being
heard you get violence so if
environmental activists are upset and
all they do is sit in the middle of the
road and chain their hands together and
then we pick them up and remove them
everybody's inconvenienced it's better
than their passing laws
I'm saying it's like it's like antifa
going around fire bombing build up
buildings is like why won't this stop
people there there has to be a
reasonable pressure relief pressure
release in politics and that is
non-violent Civil Disobedience yeah but
I mean that's I think that's fine
therapy might also help those people
what about throwing tomato soup Masters
yeah no absolutely all these things are
fun I'm talking a policy being when
proposed and passed yeah you know you're
not wrong well I'm just saying
non-violence over Disobedience to me is
what we tolerate and going beyond that
is what we do not tolerate so if
environmentalists or any protester wants
to block a road we roll our eyes we
remove them from the road we are
inconvenienced but we say
we get it like people want to be heard
they want to be disruptive to the point
but we don't want them disrupted to the
point where they're hurting destroying
so non-violence of disobedience is the
mechanism by which we allow people to
protest the system do you think if you
stopped got out of your car and we're
like I'm on my way to a climate change
speech
they would move for you no this is what
you guys know wait hold on no yes
they make fake pamphlets of you as a
climate change speaker and then if you
ever get blocked go out there and go
guys high five dude this is me look this
is what I'm doing I'm going to a speech
right now we're doing a rally I'm so
thankful for you guys to be here do you
mind if letting me go to the rally and
they'll be like you got it buddy and
then you go and then you go to your gas
test your gasoline everyone's filling up
their their tractors and you make one
for all of them you make one for Trans
rights
and then no matter where you get stopped
you end up finding a way out of it
that's right you're like you're rifling
through your pants you're like oh wait
wrong one here's another one if you're
driving down the street and a bunch of
people are rioting you you open up your
glove box and look for whichever cause
flag it is you got black lives matter
perfect then you pull it out and you
wave and you go yeah but I'll give you
guys some advice uh legitimately people
don't realize this having been on the
ground in tons of these riots
if you are in your car and you slowly
drive up to intersection with people
protesting screaming or rioting and you
Hong can tell them to move they will
destroy your car if you honk and raise
your physical yeah they'll let you right
through one of the counter arguments I'm
not telling you to do that because it's
messed up that you have to bend the knee
to them but just keep that in mind I
don't know if this is a counter argument
but you we there is this new Passover
phenomenon where during the riots
they'll put up like a black lives matter
flag in their business which is like
please don't attack me they do but they
still get attacked anyway no no well
I've seen some very funny memes where
they are there's a there's a picture out
of Hamburg Germany where the entire
storefront all the storefronts are
destroyed just the one left one in the
Middle with an antifa sign was left
alone that's incredible go to Berkeley
and what you'll see is every business
has some kind of pro leftist sign in the
window otherwise they will smash the
window out what's that famous picture of
like a single mother-owned business
space don't destroy this in in in
Oakland uh and this is not during any
protest or anything just in Oakland in
General on a random day there was a
Burger King and it said this is a family
owned Burger King franchise please don't
destroy please you know please don't
vandalize our business and that was just
normal because the violent extremists
that are so prevalent in the Bay Area on
any given day you have to put up that
please don't hurt me I went to a bar and
they had Trump is a is a pig or
something in the window and the
bartender was talking about stuff and
she did not sound like a leftist so I
said you put that thing in the window
about Trump and she's like oh we put
that there and I was like do you really
not like him and she was like oh I don't
care it's just they'll smash the windows
if we don't yeah yep imagine wanting to
live there and then she told me a story
about how she got injured like
permanently injured because uh she's
white she said that she was walking down
the street and some people were like
she's white get her and they started
beating her up and they hurt her knee or
something and I'm just like why do you
live here yeah I don't get it there's so
many people who live in those
environments that don't even know
they're supposed to be afraid like yeah
but also like I mean for a lot of them
to get stuck you can't afford to move
the hipsters do it yeah I mean I know
who you're talking about the hipsters
will do it voluntarily and just act like
it's normal well that's in Minneapolis
I'm from Minnesota and that's what
happened in uptown right like during
2020 all the businesses got destroyed
and they're all getting spray painted
you know the front of these these uh all
of these local businesses and what the
city was doing is they were charging a
fee basically they said you have 72
hours to remove all this graffiti and if
you don't you're going to be we're going
to cover it for you and we're going to
charge you for doing that and so then
they vote for these policies not
realizing that this is your own fault
for this happening but it doesn't reach
their brain that there's a way that they
could get themselves out of this but
because they're too used to it it's
assimilated into the way they live their
lives it's the kind of the whole
rhetorical and harm reduction strategies
there's just sort of this acceptance
that everything is awful and the best we
can do is maybe make it slightly less
awful and then you look at El Salvador
and go oh wait they were the most
violent country in the entire world five
years ago and now they have less murders
than the state I'm from yeah a little
weird I'm from New Jersey it's one of
the safest states and I think have a
lower murder rate per capita than we do
yeah I think it's some people have said
El Salvador is now like the lowest crime
in the Americas I think it was the and I
think the murder rate so far this year
is out to like two per hundred thousand
or something you know from 150 like for
just for context Chicago was murder rate
I think it's 30 for every 100 000 people
El Salvador was 150. so you know just
because just being uh was at its peak so
just being out in you know an ordinary
area in the middle of daytime could be
as dangerous as the worst place in
Chicago and that's just your daily life
so yes they're I mean there are policies
are things that we're not
constitutionally work here but the
people there seem to view uh the
president as a hero even if there are
some human rights violations which
obviously we wouldn't have tolerant here
but it's sort of a different ball game
when you're that dangerous
now Salvador sounds like fun man they
got Bitcoin yeah people keep hitting me
up you got to come Max Kaiser is like
when are you coming it's just like it's
really hard to just do that though he's
down Max Kaiser's downtown he's
basically running the place he's like I
don't know I don't know exactly yeah uh
naive I think naive uh Kelly yeah uh
he's I'm pretty sure he's probably
advising on a lot of these issues and
it's kind of funny to see you know Max
Kaiser and Stacy going down to El
Salvador and being party to cleaning up
an entire country granted the president
gets all the credit naive but uh they're
also down there advocating for these for
these policies these changes and it's
just like man
like Max and Stacy just went down there
and we're like we're gonna clean this
place up and now
it's it's remarkable what you hear
economics you know the economy
skyrocketing
yeah we got to figure it out
Luke you know we're talking to Luke
about setting up a studio down there or
something obviously Max is hugely in
favor of it but there's a lot of people
who are moving down there and investing
in beachfront properties they have
Bitcoin Beach down there
yup sounds like a reality TV show too
right that could be a spin-off yes
Bitcoin Beach
yeah and then when when they went around
arresting all the gang members the
corporate press here got mad yeah like
how dare he uh because they're and the
thing about the game was like listen
obviously in America we have due process
but the thing about the gang members in
El Salvador is they tattoo the gang
they're part of on their body yeah so it
makes the process a bit easier to screen
them out when it literally says
yes anyway not a smart idea thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time